uh john in an effort to advance the
public's understanding of what happened
in the in the zamarri operation okay can
you explain that the hellfire missiles
apparently have these blades
can can you explain how operationally
that worked and to avoid civilian
casualties with the capabilities those
missiles are and how it all played out
no
all right how about this one
last night a senior official was asked
you know
to avoid any doubt being aired about
whether in fact it wasn't working it was
targeted
there's multiple intelligence sources
multiple methods is there anything you
can tell us
to avoid any doubt being aired about the
fact that it was in fact zawari who was
killed
there's a limit to how much detail we
can provide on this
i would tell you that
it's a combination of visual evidence
and evidence
collected through other means
that
led us to
the certainty
before
that this was
the guy
and
that led us to the conclusion after
with a high degree of confidence
that he was no more
is it physical evidence
it's it's a
visual evidence and
and uh and and
evidence collected through through other
means i really think that's about as far
as i can go
but the assessment is
high confidence
that uh
that we got who we were aiming for and i
think you know just without getting into
more detail i mean just the
the various things that
uh
the people on the ground did afterward
also
helped us come to that conclusion